hey what's up guys my name is Jonah and
welcome to episode 17 of network chat
programming so last time of course we
did the awesome awesome task of checking
out our server for setting it up and and
having it receive a packet and that
worked and was awesome
so that's great but now let's go on to
actually are implementing a method for
the server to really manage clients okay
so at the moment right we are we're not
using this sand function of the server
and the reason is you know what we're
receiving this packet here and we're
printing it out to the cons of course
but then um if we want to if we want to
reply to that client we currently have
no way to do that okay and it's not as
simple as you think it might be okay
because the reason is we don't know the
clients I Peters of course when when you
create a server and when you connect to
the server when we actually launch our
client so if I go to login Java here and
hit the debug button you can see that we
actually specify an IP address and a
port and of course that is the IP
address of the server the location the
logical location of the server and the
port of the server right so the IP
address and the port we specify that but
when the server accepts a client
connection you know we haven't handled
that we have to say okay there's a new
client connecting to me let's actually
store it in some kind of list so that I
now know where the client has connected
from and like when he connected whatever
his name whatever IP address port so
that if need be I can send him a packet
okay right so how can we do that
well client or Java contains all the
information we need right an eye net
address and a and a port number right in
fact let's just I just want to put this
a bit better let's maybe bring this down
arc I can see the addresses up here but
let's maybe bring these like that and
then separate the GUI components here
diagram socket I bring that up here
jpanel I'll bring that down okay cool
I'm just going to reordered this and
thread we might just keep like here or
something okay so um you know this has
al information media then it's a client
but the thing is obviously it's got all
this GUI stuff it's also got a it's also
got these
these sockets it's just way too heavy
wait so what we want to do is we want to
kind of create we want to kind of create
like a client like a server client kind
of thing okay and essentially it's like
a struct
but of course Java doesn't have structs
so we'll have to use a class but
essentially it's just going to be a
class that just contains a few a few
values okay so over here in our in
server in our server folder I'm going to
right click on that hit new and hit
class and what I'm really going to call
is pretty much client but I'm not going
to call it client because we might get
confused with client or Java this isn't
a different package by the way so it
will let us credit with with an end
client but I'm just going to call it
server client and the reason I'm doing
that again is so that we don't get
confused between the client that is in
the Cherno Chad package and the client
that is in the server package because
how different things of course I'll hit
finish on that and here we have our
server client class so what kind of
things should we store about the client
right this class exists to store
information about a client that is
connected to us so the couple of things
right first of all it probably makes
sense to store the name the client okay
again this is kind of irrelevant but
well it no it's very relevant but what I
mean is is they're open to the
networking part of this but it is still
relevant because we want to be able to
you know bring up a list of our clients
we want to identify them by name maybe
instead of by addresses because we're
humans and we like names not numbers so
public a string name and we'll also use
that's probably yeah
okay so we'll have an owner address
which is the IP address of the client
let's just import that of course we'll
also have a port number of course so
public and port mouse tells the client
client support now the other things that
we need is a public final int ID and a
protector by the hell is appreciated
public int attempt okay and we'll set it
equal to zero so first of all what is ID
okay port address now I'm sure you guys
can figure that one out but what on
earth is ID and attempt well
ID is a is is kind of like the idea
to figure number that we give to our
client okay and the reason we need this
thing is because um if we just use
something like address as the identifier
okay let's just say someone from your
house is connecting to this server
that's at my house now that creates a
bit of a problem in a way because um you
might have a brother you might have
another person in your household with
the same external IP address who's
actually connecting to my server so
suddenly we have two clients with the
same address problem port number okay
hmm
basically there can be if we if we were
to use address and port as the identify
so in other words we might have
something like one and two dot one sixty
eight dot zero to ten and then the port
number which is like two five three four
four three whatever and we actually kind
of made that into an identifier by
getting rid of all this and that was the
identifier oh that's cool
but sometimes there can actually be the
same port and the same IP address I know
that is if you connect with the exact
same client on the exact same computer
to the exact same server you can some
you can actually sometimes duplicate the
ports okay so it's a bad idea to UM to
do that because it's not it in some
scenarios you might actually end up with
two clients connected with the same IP
address and the same port so what we
want to do is kind of make it random
okay we want to make this a randomly
generated number that is unique and
we'll talk about actually generating a
unique ID for the client
in the future but that's on board right
now now attempt what is attempt now an
attempt is really used for for a lot of
things because for example let's just
let's just picture it this way I think
it's probably going to be the best way
to explain if if if a client suddenly
like his internet connection drops out
for a minute the clients internet
connection drops out for a minute
the server is going to like basically
trying all and the server just has to
contact the client for some reason it'll
send a packet and it might expect to
reply but it doesn't get a reply so then
it says okay well I'm going to increment
attempt by one so and this is the second
after sending the same packet because
it's been a while span like I don't know
five seconds and there has not been an
automated reply so let's try again and
it does that and we could set it to say
let's just say five okay
basically when attempt is are greater
than or equal to five then just drop the
client so it always kick the client kind
of kick it basically get the client out
of our list of connected clients because
clearly that line is all connected
connected anymore now how does this why
does this happen how does this work
the most the most I guess most popular
use of this is probably going to be um
checking to see if clients have
disconnected without formally
disconnecting so if someone was to
simply uh you know a goat of like file
exit or just hit the close button on
their application we could handle and we
could say okay if if the person has like
hit alt f4 or command Q or arm or just
hit the the X button the close button on
their window then let you send a packet
to the server being like oh yeah I've
disconnected now if if the client quits
by holding down the power button on this
computer while I'm plugging in from the
PowerPoint or going to task manager and
ending that process without actually you
know without actually giving the the
operating system and the program a
chance to close then obviously no Packer
is going to be sent to the server being
like I'm out so that's why the server
every five seconds or so maybe every two
seconds up to you really probably
depending on the load how many clients
there are every every every couple every
few seconds or so the server will just
send there a behind-the-scenes packet to
the client and be like you know hey you
still here and and then the client will
be like yeah bro I'm always here in in
reply so that's how that's going to kind
of work that's why attempt exists but of
course if the server doesn't send a
packet being like are you there bro and
the client just does not reply and the
server sends a packet five times and the
client still hasn't replied then it
drops the client okay so public server
client the constructor here they'll take
a few parameters first of all the name
second of all the are di net address of
course then the port then the ID
and the name okay and we will set this
dot ID equal to ID we'll also set this
table address equal to address this dot
equal to port and this sort name equal
to name
alright sweat oh we do this twice whoops
okay and let's just order this properly
all right cool so got the name of the ID
the ID Olivia last year the name the
address support and the ID again in this
class of course all these are public
which means that we've got basically
read and write access to them and that's
how we're going to use them okay so the
ID should probably be private and we
should probably make a getter for it
just because we don't want to be able to
accidentally get ID we don't it be able
to accidentally um write to all we won't
be able to anyway because it's final
it's a good point but that's alright
we'll still make a get ID function here
okay sweet so this is our server client
class pretty simple now let's see it in
action
so how is it's going to work right when
a client gets connected to a server like
how does the server manage these clients
and it's really very simple
okay all we need to have here is a
private list containing server client
which is of course this class that we
just created so private list server
client clients equals new ArrayList and
server client all right all right let's
import all this make sure that you do
import the utility interface here from
the utility loss instead of the UM AWT
list because that's just like a GUI list
if we want an actual list here an actual
array and we've got clients now which is
brilliant that's all we need to do right
and basically whenever we get a specific
packet which we will talk about next
episode we'll talk about how to actually
send a packet that isn't a message in
other words how we can kind of send like
a coded packet being like this is this
is a connection packet this is a
disconnection packet this is a time-out
packet or whatever how we can actually
send these special
packets so that um the server knows how
to interpret them instead of just you
know printing the message and sending
out the message as if it was just a
normal text message so what we'll do
here is when we receive this packet yeah
just to test this we won't actually
leave this here but just to test this
we're going to go ahead and say once we
get the string here we want to go ahead
and say let's create a new let's just go
clients dot add new server client okay
and then the parameters that we need of
course are name so we're gonna go ahead
and just call the name Yount for now
doesn't matter uh net address so how do
we get the address of the client that
has just sent us a message right so
we've just received a packet from a
client so how can we get the the source
address in the source port and the thing
is I it doesn't matter if you use a UDP
or TCP the header file of both of those
protocols contains always both the
destination address and the source
address okay so this packet actually has
the source address of where it came from
so we can simply access that by hitting
our packet dot get address and that will
return an iron address here we can also
um hit up a packet dot get port to get
the port and then the other thing we
need is an ID so we'll just set that
like 54 now it's cool all right
and that's it you can see if that
doesn't give us any errors and that is
how we add a new server client brilliant
so what we can do now is I'm actually
just going to call this from here and
make it an object so we can access it
here I'll actually no no don't you dare
I'll just go clients zero so system dot
out dot print line again just just to
test this out let's see probably just
print out so ok clients so clients don't
get zero get this isn't the safe thing
to do but it is temporary so chill
client get zero dots address oh ok hang
on
I knit a dress should have a on it a
dress you have a way convert into a
string ah it does have a two string yep
two string okay so it overwrites objects
two string brilliant Plus that plus the
port number so clients dot clients dot
get zero dot put okay so we'll just
print it out the client on the port as
it's connected and then we print out the
actual string okay so let's let's just
launch this and see what happens I'm
going to bring my console up here and up
here then I'm going to go to login and
just launch that quickly but just not a
not actually hit login on that and then
I'm going to of course sell the server
by going a server main and hitting the
debug button here it is service solid
report eight one line to that I'm going
to flip over to this login window here
type in Y on localhost is the IP address
of the server and a 192 is the the port
of the server then we're going to go
ahead and hit login
so what do we see here well if we
actually just get out of that basically
and quit that and go back here we can
see that this is the information that
got printed out by this line over here
this line okay so the address to string
gave us 127.0.0.1 which of course is the
same as localhost that is the numeric
representation of localhost of the word
localhost so in other words um in other
words if we were in this login screen if
we were to type in instead of going
ahead and typing in localhost we could
have just gone 127.0.0.1 because that is
actually equal that actually equals
localhost okay
so let's flip back to our running server
man here by the debug tab again and then
this is the port number so force when we
actually create a server in client
I'm sorry whenever we create a well I
guess whenever we open a socket but as
the client you can see over here that in
the
open connection method this diagram
socket is not take any parameters which
means that if I mouse over this and get
the Javadoc
it can suck in construction data grams
lock it binds it to any available port
okay so in this case is chosen five six
nine one two fifty six thousand nine
hundred twelve because of course ports
can be pretty much anything from 0 to
65535 which is to the power of six in so
well six five six five five three six is
to the power of 16 but anyway so that's
anywhere between that's been anywhere in
16bits we can have a port number so that
that's probably more some in-depth
episode content there but um that is the
the source IP address and the source
port of where that packet came from and
of course now that we've added it to our
prefer go back to server here now that
we've added it to our clients array we
now have a client we have the details of
a particular client here so that is
episode 17 of network I programming if
you guys did enjoy the video please hit
like button and again 200 likes one
video per day 300 likes two videos per
day and then next time we'll hopefully
talk about how we can send a connection
packet to the server and then say okay
this is me not just sending a random
message this is me telling the server
I'm connecting to you so yeah and I'll
see you guys next time
good bye